est-ce que oui ou non sont-elles levés à
baiser avec un des nuls non et c'est pas
on a franchement on a essayé
donc là est tellement discret qu'on va
faire une interview la vérité sur Alain
Chabat
est-ce que oui ou non vous avez pécho
par ici le temps la semaine dernière à
Los Angeles
non j'étais à Tourcoing est-ce que oui
ou non on fait les Winter vous a mis
dans son CV à la rubrique expérience
professionnelle
non mais c'est une très bonne
est-ce que oui ou non vous avez perdu 10
kilos
non
est-ce que oui ou non vous êtes toujours
faim qui fraîche alors
oui je suis funky fresh je suis je
l'apparence comme ça d'un garçon un
petit peu un petit peu gros un petit peu
mais à l'intérieur je suis un grand noir
extrêmement musclé qui est très bien
est-ce que oui ou non vous êtes heureux
moins depuis que vous arrêtez mais sinon
oui
[Applaudissements]
parce que oui ou non vous êtes
devenu Hollywood
je suis je j'essaye de d'importer la
merguez Hollywood dans ce moment je
travaille là-dessus je pense qu'il y a
un marché qui est intéressant est-ce que
vous venant depuis 5 ans pour échapper
toutes les actrices françaises que vous
voulez à la
Charlotte
oui bien sûr est-ce que oui ou non
Dominique farroja vous surnomme le
serpent à lunettes oui mais il m'énerve
c'était mon surnom le serpent à lunettes
est-ce que oui ou non les nuls vont se
reformer un jour peut-être en tout cas
nous sortons un DVD
à la rentrée
est-ce que oui ou non Chantal lobby à
baiser avec un des nuls non et c'est pas
on a franchement on a essayé
on voulait rien savoir est-ce que ou non
canal est avant tout une aventure
humaine merveilleuse dans laquelle vous
avez vécu les plus belles années de
votre vie et qui vous a permis
d'accomplir vos rêves les plus fous
merci oui canal et avant tout une
aventure merveilleuse
dans laquelle j'ai pu accomplir mes
rêves les plus fous et je me souviens
plus bien du milieu de la France
rappelons que l'anagramme de Alain
Chabat donne habitat canal
j'ai trouvé ça en cherchant en rangeant
des cassettes je fais ça toute la
semaine Laurent est-ce que oui ou non
vous avez retrouvé l'esprit canal avec
Stéphane Bern à mort
est-ce que oui ou non vous la péter un
peu depuis Astérix je me la suis
toujours pété c'était avant Astérix
est-ce que oui ou non vous étiez un
danger pour le gouvernement et c'est
pour ça qu'on a essayé de descendre le
film des Robins
on peut rien dire là-dessus
non
est-ce que oui ou non on préfère le
chien là maintenant
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu